re
It's a weapon of Japanese pottery, it's a
work of art, and
it's also a god for Japanese people
[Music]
[Music
] Hmm, my name is Takaya Nakanishi
.
It's the one who had the samurai
. Well, since I was little, I really liked it and often went to that museum to
go to the navigation system,
so I made it through our school.  I was interested in trying to do it, and
there it was a form of cd to a swordsmith's master. Ni became
a disciple of swordsmith
a
down. It's been about 15 years since then.
It's already Japan's cold winter iron, so
it's made using so-called forever, but it's about 1 originally with Japan.
Well, the work of sword smithing is about a week.
I have to raise it, but I'm
a woman who uses sin, but Junsei also wipes it in the inn
and sends the wind.
[Music]
It's also a feature of iphone etc. Soil before baking to make ripples.
After that, it's easy to make a hole and then sharpen
it, isn't it? Kathlito is a tool for sharpening Mars.
The difference is whether the ripples are beautiful or the iron is beautiful
. I think it's true that I'm particular about it.
Well, it's very important to get a clear idea of what to make.  I th
[Music]
Japanese swords are that church there. I wanted three elements where it was hard and not hard.
I want to be involved in making Japanese swords as long as I am alive.
I think
[music]